[Music]
hello and welcome to keep it simple 1.d4
yeah after about 15 a month after keep
it simple 1.e4 and was released now the
default version is completed and
released in here on chasuble i'm very
happy to present to you this full
repertoire for white based on 1d for it
covers basically everything that black
can do against it and I'm going to
suggest good lines for white against all
of those possible replies so before I am
going to give you an overview and some
ideas and concepts that this repertoire
includes I'm going to briefly explain to
you what keep it simple means in the
context you have this rabbit form um
they keep it simple idea is that you
should learn lines that are reasonably
simple not overly complicated some lines
tend to lead to a very complicated play
just from the get-go this is usually
avoided in some cases we definitely will
have a sharp and our confrontational
play in our repertoire but this is
mostly when black does something unsound
or something that really demands a sharp
reply we have to really play along you
cannot just always play yeah scary
chairs is bad if you have to play
aggressively you have to do it um the
lines should be reasonably safe so that
if you forget something and you're kind
of on your own you shouldn't be in a
position where let's say your king is in
terrible danger and you have to know
like ten only moves to not get
checkmated this is also important to me
so that is a practical approach and all
in all in sheer volume if you think of
this as a print book it will be a print
book in the future it shouldn't be more
than
one book shouldn't be like five books or
something um one thing it's also
important to keep in mind with and keep
it simple is that we want to keep in
mind what the opponent is doing with
every line and think about their
intentions and if possible play a little
bit of a spoil sport and play something
that they don't really like to face this
is something that is important in
particular against some aggressive
options we often playing you know in a
somewhat and let's say cooperative we're
just not going into some of the
Hawaiians is a good approach now I'd
like to also tell talk a little bit
about some general considerations while
building an opening repertoire we can
compare a little bit d4 and e4 I think
this is important too to see it
understand in particular if you see the
volume of this course and chasuble it
has many hours of video close to thirty
hours and more than 1,000 variations
that is a lot more than one for head and
there is a reason for that um if you
compare a for indie form there is one
important thing you have to see if you
play one e form and now black is
choosing an answer if you don't really
have all that many trans positions
between all those openings for example
let's say they play e5 and then in my
ear for repertoire I recommend it play
the Scourge for 9 a.m. just to show this
briefly I recommend to play this if you
start like that you know it's going to
be a 45 it's not going to transpose into
a French defense or into a Sicilian
similarly if black answers efore with a
6 it's not going to be appealed so Eric
Conn's all those opening lines after you
form they're pretty much yeah not very
dependent on one
there are rather young single parts of
one construction that are easily
interchangeable this is not so much the
case with d4 with d4 openings you simply
have the situation that all kinds of
replies may lead to the same position
and every single move deserve some
consideration because it opens up some
possibilities and it gives away some
possibilities for example if you plan
let's say like place Knight f6 just to
continue this with some moves on the
board it's a really important
consideration if you want to play the
knight to f3 or if you want to play c4
for example similarly after something
like this it is usually important if you
play the knight here or the knight here
as their black for example can play d5
or c5 or bishop before or b6 and all of
those replies would lead to versions of
openings so it is far more complex in
terms of move orders and in terms of
coherence everything has to kind of fit
well together
and this brings us to a second point
about d4 blings very often simply the
choice that both sides have is wider
compared to e4 openings
if o openings tend to be often more
direct more confrontational early on you
sometimes have really exchanges for
example just take for example an opening
let's say like the petrov where you can
often early on have an open file and
this is not so much happening in d4 like
pieces and not getting traded all that
often quickly or that the center is is
blowing up early on yeah this is also
not happening then and you often have a
huge range of setups available many porn
formations and so on and this is due to
the fact that both sides are playing
oftentimes their own game
or some more so like might have a set up
in mind so or we could have a set up in
mind some sort of formation that we want
to play for and at the same time both
sides have lots of leeway and that
simply means that the d4 abattoir is
almost invariably going to be a little
bit bigger than an e4 repertoire unless
you play the e4 repertoire in a very
sophisticated way and I can very very
much
drill down to some super complicated
main lines but just um if you want to
drill as deep as we want in a cupid
simple context there are just more
options than black hairs and therefore
we need to look at a little bit more
this is of course very challenging in
some some way because how do you handle
this wide range of possibilities I
looked at um some approaches when I
developed this repertoire and one
consideration there pretty early on
crossed my mind is what do we do with
the f1 Bishop there are two general
approaches you can KanCare to the bishop
or you can use it on its starting
diagonal often going to e2 later d3
something like that and I really on
wanted to go for this central way of
playing Bishop to e2 and e3 later and
I'm examined the repertoire for example
based based on this well based on main
lines in the in the King's Indian and so
on however quickly realized that this is
pretty much never going to be as simple
as you want it to be because it is
invariably becoming complicated in those
lines and also there are advisors a wide
range of poor informations possible then
it's also something that kind of
deterred me a little bit plus there are
many trap lines like C 5 V 5 V 5 the
Bangko or the modern benoni or lines
that in many mm in many games
my experiences where black being the
specialist in those lines um is often
having the easier life and then I
checked g3 setups like d4 Knight f6 c4
and whatever they do play like g3 this
is the approach that Boris abrooke is
some following in his deform repertoire
series the GM repertoire um and this is
definitely a viable approach but still
also very sophisticated in many in many
ways um when I looked at this at the g3
lines it suddenly hit me that many lines
really get complicated because of the c4
pond and this is just one example that I
can make for example him if you think
about the bank oh this is possible
because there's a pawn on c4 1 in lines
of the Queen's Gambit if we look at
Queens gambit black can immediately take
from the Queens gambit accepted or he
can play lines for example like this or
if you look at g3 base setup like this
where it takes a pawn and oftentimes
initiates very concrete tactical
concrete tactical play these are the
lines that really make it often
difficult because you really have some
cop-out option where you still can play
for something you often have to play the
real main line
[Music]